- Welcome back, before we say goodbye
we like to play a quick round of-
- Drewth or dare!
(people cheering)
- Today we have Logan Johnson.
Hi Logan.
- Hi Drew, hi Ross.
- How are y'all?
- Thank you, I'm good.
I wanted to thank you both
for everything you do.
This show is so beautiful and
it's my daily dose of joy.
- Aah.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(people cheering)
Thank you so much.
- Is it gonna be a Drewth or a dare?
- It's going to be a dare.
- Okay.
- Whoa!
- We've never said no
before, so bring it on.
- Okay. You ready?
- Yeah.
- I love sour foods.
I dare you to eat a quarter of a lemon
while keeping a total poker face.
- I love this dare!
- Ah.
- Do you have a lemon?
- Someone does.
(people laughing)
- Oh.
- We just found some on the desk.
- Okay. Three, two, go.
- Ooh.
(people laughing)
- Oh god! I failed!
(people cheering)
- I now wanna see more people do this
and see who can and can't,
'cause it was impossible
not to make the pickle face.
- Mm hmm.
- It's a new TikTok challenge.
Try it home, try it at home.
- Hey.
- Let's start one.
- Let's do it.
- Let's do it right now.
- Yes, #lemonface.
- We challenge you to a TikTok challenge.
Can you eat a lemon and
keep a straight face?
I'll tell you, I couldn't do it.
- Mm hmm.
Let's see-
- Can you do it?
- Let's see if this happens.
(people cheering)
Thank you so much, Logan.
- Thank you.
- And thank you
for your kind words.
- Thank you.
- Really and truly.
(people cheering)
'Cause that is actually the whole point.
I just wanna thank everyone
for choosing to spend their time with us,
because, to Logan's point,
we make this show for you.
So take it with you and
thank you so much for coming,
everybody.
(people cheering)
Thank you.
(upbeat music)